alors c'est Cyril Hanouna et bouder
ils ont passé le BEP ensemble et le jour
des résultats bah Cyril il peut pas
venir il me dit bouder s'il te plaît je
peux pas venir je dois passer la journée
avec mes parents et par contre
appelle-moi pour me dire les résultats
mais on va mettre une stratégie en place
comme je vais être en haut parleur si
j'ai raté un examen tu me dis allô Cyril
comment tu vas si j'ai raté deux examens
tu me dis allô Cyril comment tu vas et
comment il va ton père
on arrive le lundi je regarde les
résultats j'appelle Cyril il y a le
Cyril comment tu vas toi ton père ta
mère
[Applaudissements]
à Casablanca il y a un taxi là à l'arrêt
et là tout de suite il y a une dame qui
rentre elle est complètement nue elle
rentre elle s'installe derrière elle est
complètement à poils comme un fou il
regarde dans le rétroviseur et la dame
elle dit mais écoutez monsieur
j'ai jamais vu une femme toute nue et
qui mange je me demande juste il est où
l'argent pour que tu payes la course
[Applaudissements]
à partir de janvier 2023 quand on ouvre
les conneries et toute la France pour
écrire par deux amis j'aime beaucoup
merci écoute c'est un mec qui est
persuadé que sa femme le trompe tu vois
et donc il décide de rentrer à
l'improviste c'est-à-dire il rentre à
13h il rentre jamais à 13h si jamais
arrivé de sa vie toi très très énervé il
habite au 15e étage d'une tour tu vois
et il rentre monte dans l'ascenseur il
est comme ça il est sûr qu'il va la
pécho tu vois il ouvre la porte en furie
et ça ça tombe pile trouve sa femme dans
le couloir à poil toute transpirante et
lui dit il est où il est où cet [ __ ]
fouille partout il va dans la chambre
sur le lit sous le lit il ouvre toutes
trouve rien toi et à un moment il se
souvient que du haut de son 15e étage il
a la chance d'avoir un petit balcon tu
vois avec une porte fenêtre comme ça je
dirigea porte fenêtre il ouvre et là il
le voit
il est là
le mec il
est avec 15 étages en dessous de lui
dire [ __ ] et lui tape sur les doigts
toi le mec il lâche pas que il tient il
tient toi
il prend une chaise pour être un peu
plus haut lui piétine les doigts et
piétine le mec continue à tenir
[Applaudissements]
rentre dans la maison il va dans sa
caisse à outils pour un marteau et lui
pète tous les doigts les uns les autres
à la fin le mec qui tient plus par le
petit doigt comme ça
il lâche il tombe de 15 étages
heureusement il y a trois ou quatre
arbres bien serrés en dessous
qui tu le crois tu le crois pas qui lui
amortisse sa chute
4 5 branches et il est immobilisé avant
de toucher le sol l'autre en haut et
regarde
il bouge encore
[Rires]
chez lui il attrape le frigidaire c'est
un monstre le frigidaire il prend en
parole
[Applaudissements]
et seul mais sur les dents et papa il va
vers la porte ce nez je traverse le
petit balcon il bute dans la rambarde le
frigo passe au-dessus lui il tombe sur
la gueule du mec donc le mec meurt
il arrive chez Saint-Pierre
si c'est important vous allez voir pour
la suite et
ding dong
il dit voilà j'étais sûr que ma femme me
trompais je suis en train d'improviste
et ça a pas loupé je suis tombé dessus
voilà alors bon j'ai fait un truc pas
très sympa je le dis tout de suite
Saint-Pierre c'est vrai mais qui était
accroché par rappel du balcon et dit
j'ai été jusqu'à prendre un marteau j'ai
pété tous les doigts jusqu'à ce qu'il a
ch et puis c'est [ __ ] là il bougeait
encore
été bloquée par les arbres donc j'ai
pris le frigo et je lui ai foutu sur la
gueule donc Saint-Pierre il dit bah
écoutez mettez-vous là à côté qui c'est
pas banal que l'histoire ni asseyez-vous
je vais vous prendre tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et là il y a un autre mec qui se qui se
pointe il dit et vous monsieur qu'est-ce
qui vous est arrivé bah écoutez moi je
suis peintre en bâtiment
si vous voulez j'étais en train de
repeindre un balcon au 17e étage
d'une tour je vais presque fini mon
travail il me restait une petite
retouche à faire à l'extérieur
je me suis penché la peinture était
fraîche donc glissante tu vois et
je suis tombé mais grâce à Dieu je sais
pas par quel miracle j'ai réussi à me
rattraper au balcon du 15e étage
et dit là j'ai vu un mec arrivé vers moi
en furie
les yeux exorbitaires et au lieu de
m'aider au lieu de m'aider
hanter il m'a tapé sans les doigts il y
a un moment elle a pris un marteau et il
m'a piqué tous les doigts et je suis
tombé grâce à Dieu aussi je suis tombé
sur un art très touché très gentil
qui m'a empêché de m'écraser au sol je
me suis dit merci mon Dieu j'ai pas fini
de penser ça le mec qui m'a envoyé un
frigo de 2 tonnes en pleine tête et je
suis
morte
du monsieur hein je vais vous prendre
une
retentit à nouveau Jean-Pierre dit mais
c'est une série ce matin ou quoi
disez-vous Monsieur que si vous arrivez
et là le mec il dit que tu es moi j'ai
rien compris
j'étais caché à poil dans un frigidaire
[Applaudissements]